okay this is a peppa panning saga level
407 walkthrough tutorial i'm making this
for a request that we had in our
facebook group
one of the members was having trouble
with it it is
a frustrating level and it's one that
players have complained about um
i don't think it's the worst level or
the hardest level
it is a little bit boring because
there's a lot of colors and it's
frustrating because you can't get a
chain reaction to go
generally speaking there's a strategy
you have to use the grills you have to
hold off on making explosions until you
can set it up to make a big one and
it's not fun but it is beatable
i would say beatable consistently so
um
just
if you haven't seen our girls tutorial
video watch that if you don't understand
how these things work and take a long
time to explain it in this video so
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
try to set up i got a gap here for five
pepper orange so i'm going to try to set
that up
um
those are the best matches we can get so
we want to make them and
set him up whenever we can
we're going to try to work around the
cat as much as possible
so when he's at the bottom we're going
to
work at the top
you know we discussed that
i guess probably about 11 months ago
when we wrote our guide on him how that
worked so
by this time 400 levels you're probably
pretty familiar with
what to do when the cat's around
so
he's gonna come back up
so right now i'm not super concerned
with these orange peppers because
there's not much i can
do so i'm just going to try to um
you know move around to what's the best
available matches and when he gets up a
little bit then i'll go below him again
you know i moved that over there because
i mean i wasn't really expecting the red
to explode there what i was trying to do
was um
set it up for the next match but it
exploded so i'll take that every time
i'm looking at the girls i don't see
anything too fantastic when we have
another five pepper gap here
but
with so many colors
dropping from the from the board is it's
it's not really a high percentage play
so instead what i'm going to do is i'm
going to match these yellows and that's
going to drop and explode that orange
the last time we set up the five pepper
made a lot more sense because we can see
the match already there
in desperation um
it's never
it's always okay to try that
you know where you drop a unknown pepper
down
but
on a board with a lot of colors it's
just like i said you just have less
chance of
making it work
so all right um
this is a pretty awesome
we are in a pretty awesome position now
we got our first panic
with 21 moves left i mean that doesn't
happen if you played this a lot you know
that doesn't happen and if you watch our
other video
it didn't happen that way on that one
either
but
you can see how taking your time and
planning things out and just the simple
idea of staying away from the cat and
making explosions on the grill can lead
to that it won't do it every time but
that's what you want to have happen
and if you get down to like where you
have about 10 moves left and that
happens instead of 21 you still have a
really good chance to finish because you
have your recharge
booster that you can use
and um
you know things get a lot simpler at
that point
so now you can see we have this l
and we have this for pepper um
neither one of them is great because
neither one's going to explode anything
on the grill
but the purple one is a match on the
grill so
i'm gonna make this first it doesn't
look like it's gonna anything's gonna
mess up our blue but if it does it's not
the end of the world either
all right so now i'll make this um
there's no reason to pass that out
and that gave us a little bit of
side side action
all right so now
we are in a spot
where we have our brand new rechargeable
booster and we should probably move it
use it on this match
and what i'm gonna do um
i mean with nineteen moves you know you
could actually wait for a while to use
it
but
you're not getting used to gonna have
that many so i'm just gonna play it as
if like we're at the end i guess
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna put it
here i'm gonna make a four pepper match
it's gonna um
make a yellow
match on the grills um it's only one but
it's better than nothing and it's also
gonna explode this red pepper and move
things around
and the moving things around part is
what's gonna help us out
so
i guess i made a mistake there um
it's very little it doesn't really
matter that much but
the other one
i kind of knew it wasn't going to
explode but i said it was going to grow
that and that's not what happened
it only grows that if it explodes on it
so
here
um we got a lot of grown reverends
around
there's no way to explode one on the
grill
um
i don't know this is this probably isn't
going to lead to a panic but it's going
to explode a couple peppers fit things
around and maybe we'll get lucky
and have a good setup after the cascade
it's not a bad setup
now we can explode this red that'll
start a little chain reaction
and
it'll clear the red off the board
effectively and you know potentially set
up more
matches with other colors
alright so now we're in good shape
but we do need to
let's see what are these three six nine
yeah so we're going to go ahead and
start a chamber that reaction with these
so we don't lose all these
it doesn't look like there's enough
purple to start a panic though
unfortunately
but again you can see the board is
getting less and less of the other
colors you know it's getting more
monochromatic or whatever so
it should lead to some good action
and we got a five pepper that's going to
cause an explosion and grow some other
stuff so
looks like we're well on our way to
starting panic number two at this point
and there it is
so that's the way you have to do it um
we had 13 moves left over so like i said
if we would have started
you know if we would have got that first
panic 13 moves later it would have been
exactly the same
so don't worry about that don't worry
about how many you have um the first one
takes more moves than the second one
does
that's because you'll have the the
rechargeable there and you know you get
a nice cascade afterwards
so that makes a big difference
is you know you usually have some grown
peppers starting out instead of starting
from scratch so um i hope this helps
everybody who's having trouble with this
level
if you have any questions leave them in
the comments
please like the video if you found it
helpful that really helps me out
and
i would really appreciate that
make sure you check out our site and
then join our facebook group if you have
any questions like i said i made this
for facebook facebook group member who
was having a problem so
you can come in there we got about 76 or
100 or so people in it and it's really
active and fun
so everyone's welcome to join
thanks